[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes from spectator tv i'm fraser
nelson and your host this week
on the show the queen's jubilee the
nation is celebrating but has the
monarchy somehow managed to make itself
more relevant rather than less as the
decades have gone past i'll be talking
to james forsyth and to christopher
house
and then to another institution of
marriage fewer people are getting
hitched than ever before but should we
worry louise perry says we should from a
feminist point of view an institution
she says it started to protect women on
net more than men i'll be speaking to
her
and then on to ukraine might putin's
luck have turned kate andrews talks to
the historians anthony beaver and sir
employee
and 40 years old since the tiananmen
square massacre how has china changed
it's got a lot rich but culturally it's
going into reverse says cindy she joins
me as well and finally why is it so
difficult to get a face-to-face
appointment with gps marilyn thomas
joins me and says it's down to do the
new nhs system called total triage we'll
discuss it later
and before we start a special offer if
you don't subscribe to the spectator
then this is the perfect chance to try
our marketing department are offering a
economically unwise deal for just one
pound you get 10 weeks of the magazine
10 weeks full digital access and a
spectator jubilee tea towel just for a
quid so to avail yourself of this um
deeply and economically daft idea then
go to spectator dot co dot uk forward
slash platinum
anyway on to that jubilee christopher
house was spectator's former production
editor and our portrait of the week
writer joins me with james forsyth to
discuss the mystery of the monarchy why
is it that now in 2022 it should enjoy
popularity way greater than politicians
and of anything more strong than it was
a quarter of a century ago christopher
let's start with you would you say
you're a monarchists and if so why
well i think i would call myself monicus
because i support a sort of hierarchical
system and the best kind of hierarchy is
where you have a very powerful figure at
the top apparently who has no real power
so it really is a question of the crown
in parliament and we saw that when the
queen couldn't make the state opening of
parliament and
the prince of wales was sitting next to
a table where lord chumney had very
kindly put a a crown on a cushion next
to him and it was the crown that was the
thing opening parliament really and he
was just the mouthpiece for it
much better than the president
james you and i have spoken about
politics for many many years but not
really the monarchy where do you stand
on this would you describe yourself as a
monarchist
well i think i would say that i was
intellectually attracted to
republicanism but i actually think that
in practice
uh the monarchy uh works partly for the
reasons that christopher
attested but also because as our
democratic politics has become more and
more divisive
uh i think that the queen in particular
and the monarchy in general acts as
uh something above politics that can
unify the country you know you look at
the celebrations that they'll take place
this weekend it is impossible to imagine
those celebrations taking place for for
any president
and i think that because you have a head
of state who is not political whose
views we do not know in a host of
questions it actually acts as a unifying
symbol
even as our as our as our democratic
politics uh our parliamentary politics
it is particularly fraught and i think
what i think the most remarkable
achievement of the queen's reign
is
that constitutional monarchy is so
uncontroversial in this country that
prince charles will succeed uh with with
no serious debate about whether this
country should become a republic or not
and i think that that is down to the
immense skill
with which the queen has carried out her
role
right so james those who are
intellectually attracted to
republicanism yourself and many others
who basically was quite happy with
why are they being so quiet right now
why don't we hear much of a sort of um
i can push back against this institution
in the way that we did 25 years ago
because i think that the the value of
the monarchy has become clearer in the
last quarter of a century in the last
quarter of a century i would argue that
our politics
uh has become particularly contested
and i think that therefore the value of
an institution that stands
outside and above politics has become
greater
i also think the queen herself has
handled the role with huge skill
and i think christopher talked about in
1997. i think robert harmer makes a
point in the magazine this week of all
the subtle changes that the queen has
introduced since then to the monarchy
and i also think people look at the
queen and it is impossible not to see
someone who has devoted their life to
public service and public duty and i
think that carries with it the nation's
respect i also think she works as a link
back to our history she is she is the
great link that she is a personification
of the link to to world war ii uh and
and the bravery and courage of that
generation right the christopher to what
extent is the monarchy as an institution
what has captured people's hearts and to
what extent is it the person of
elizabeth ii in other words when charles
is doing more than just reading the
state opening of parliament speech as
you mentioned when he's sitting on the
throne do you expect that will be a
moment of um concern even crisis for the
monarchy
i doubt it will be a crisis the thing is
that people really don't know why they
like the monarchy and the bounce back
from 1997 was quite quick because the
golden
jubilee
in 2002
was very popular with the people a
million people gathering together
to celebrate the jubilee and
political commentators had really been
predicting that it would be a bit of a
flop and it wasn't at all
but
it's the attempts to get rid of the
institution which have shown
why it's valuable so it's really of a
piece with tony blair trying to get rid
of the lord chancellor overnight and
then finally he couldn't because the
lord chancellor strangely enough is
an essential part of the way the
constitution works it's similar with the
queen that
if you start taking away the bricks then
you find that the
structure
is sort of cracked and doesn't work
in in a sort of living organic way
thank you christopher we can let you go
now but james if we can move from the
dignified to the efficient or the not so
efficient in this case of of 10 downing
street
i wonder if this jubilee weekend might
be boris johnson's last in them
certainly without a leadership contest
we're hearing rumors of
letters calling for a confidence vote
approaching even perhaps surpassing the
total of 54 needed to trigger a
no-confidence motion what are you
hearing
so i don't think we'll know anything for
certain until parliament returns uh next
week
but i think if you look at the number of
tory mps who've gone public saying that
they have sent a letter or that they
think boris johnson should resign it is
clear that we are very close to
uh the 54 letters required for up for
james can say what we can just say a
little bit more why that's clear because
if you look at the mps that got on the
record saying they want to be gone
there's only about 25 30 of them and not
pretty far short of 54. so where are you
getting remainder from
so
as a conservative estimate i think if
you do if you times the number of public
letters by 1.5 that gives you a fairly
conservative estimate on the number of
letters that are in
uh i also know of one albeit quite
junior minister who has sent in a letter
obviously no minister could send in a
letter and then go public because they
would have to to resign if that was what
they had done
and there will be other mps who are just
keeping their heads down and we've
talked about this before fraser the most
deafening sound at the moment is the
silence of tory mps most story mps don't
want to avoid either publicly calling
for boris johnson to go or publicly
backing him and how that that silent
majority of the party splits i i think
is another thing that will be causing
concern i think there are now some close
allies to the prime minister who regard
having to fight an unconfidence vote as
almost inevitable now i should insert
one caveat here which is there are some
people who want boris johnson gone who
are urging uh
their fellow mps not to send letters in
they their argument goes like this look
if you wait until after these two
by-elections on june the 23rd you've got
a much better chance of winning the no
confidence vote against boris johnson so
he loses two safety seats then that's
going to be regarded as the final nail
in the the arguments that he is a winner
yeah and also the fact that these two
story seats are are very different
wakefield is a seat that's been
traditionally labor that the tories won
in 2019 for the first time tiverton and
honeton uh seat in the southwest the
rural seat has been tory since it's
created in 1997 and has a 24 000
majority the argument goes if both of
those seats go on the same day that will
cause concern at kind of both ends of
the tory parliamentary party and that
could tip a ballot now i think if the
confidence ballot takes place
soon
those tory mps who know the
parliamentary party best
their view is that boris johnson would
win but by a smaller margin than theresa
may won her contest in 2018. so we're
looking at about 100 you need 180 odd
votes to depose him
under this scenario there'll be 100 120.
so theresa may got just shy of
two-thirds of the votes of her
parliamentary party the argument is that
boris johnson would win you know 60 40
or maybe slightly less than that
and
that notionally that should mean that
boris johnson would be safe from another
challenge for a year
but you know this is the tory party and
the rules can be changed very quickly
and i think if that would if boris wants
to win by that narrow margin i think
this leadership story would rumble on um
month by month with with demands for
change the rules to allow a fresh ballot
and the like or with demands that the
cabinet should go and say that the game
is up and i think the problem for the
tory party is that you can't get around
the fact it is fundamentally split on
the leadership question if boris johnson
were to be deposed i suspect there would
be a kind of mark anthony candidate in
any leadership contest
right but the problem james is that
boris johnson has made clear on quite a
few occasions that he does not want to
go from number 10
if you were to win a leadership uh even
if you win badly
then you'd pretty much need the sas to
get him out of number 10 wouldn't you i
think boris johnson would consider a
victory in a no confidence vote as as
settling the matter he would say look
it's cleared the air
under the rules i'm now safe for a year
so i should now be allowed to get on
with it i think the tory party is too
split at the moment for that to happen i
think i mean the tensions would continue
to roll uh as they did under theresa may
i think that one of the
aspects of the tory rules is that this
15 threshold offers the incumbent a lot
of protection but once it has been
breached it makes the incumbents
position more vulnerable
because the ballot that follows um
it is uh it is inherently drains the
prime minister of a considerable chunk
of our authority now finally james we've
been here before we were having these
conversations in january february and it
always seems to peter out might it just
be around again this time
yeah look there is obviously a
temptation to think that this is the boy
who cries wolf when when a political uh
journalist turns up and tells you that
the 54 letters are close to being
reached but it is worth remembering that
there was actually a wolf at the end of
that story and the second thing i would
say is it is the sheer what makes this
different i think from january and
february is the sheer number of tory mps
who have gone public uh back in january
and february it was a much smaller
number who are actually out there
publicly this time around uh you know
the numbers i suspect would have changed
by the time this is broadcast but if you
look on spectator coffee house there was
an updated list
you're talking about 30 tory mps who
have gone public
okay and as james says you can keep
track of the developments and the list
of tory rebels on our website over the
span called a weekend and as this drama
unfolds james thanks very much we'll be
back hearing from you next week to see
what if anything is
moving about 10 years ago we saw an
uptick in marriage but that was fairly
short-lived rates are right now plunging
again down to half what they were of the
peak in 1972. so is this a sign of a
more liberated society
we're delighted to have the new
statesman writer louise perry writing
for us from a spectator about this
phenomenon she has a book now out called
the case against the sexual revolution
louise great to have you with us and why
do you think that the marriage rates are
going down isn't this a sign of social
progress
so
the um crucial piece of legislation here
is the divorce reform act in 1969
which was uh one of the sort of the
great pieces of liberalizing legislation
in the the period of the beginning of
the sexual revolution
um
what's really interesting i went when i
was writing the book actually i went
back and i read hansard and i read the
debates around that piece of legislation
and um
the view at the time
was that this was just a very minor
piece of
piece of um
liberalization that would just make life
a little bit easier for people who were
in desperately unhappy marriages and and
and needed to be out of them this is of
course at the time when it was really
hard to get a divorce and you had to
prove you had to prove adultery
intolerable cruelty et cetera um and so
the view from all of the
the uh the the revolutionaries they
didn't know their revolutionaries at the
time was that you just a little tweak
and it would make things just that
little bit simpler that little bit
kinder to people who were desperate to
get divorced
um of course that's not what happened at
all what happens immediately you look at
the graph of divorce rates in the uk and
1969 is just this explosion um and you
see divorce climbs and climbs it peaks
in the 1970s and then it's kind of
leveled off or or just uh
bounced around a little bit since then
but that's not because marriages are
becoming
longer it's because people are not
getting married in the first place and
what seems to have happened is that
as soon as you sort of reach this
threshold where it was no longer assumed
that you would be married for life
you end up with this kind of
acceleration effect where
previously you would only consider a
divorce if your marriage was desperately
unhappy and then it became
the threshold became a little bit lower
and a little bit lower and a little bit
lower and now we're at the stage where
about half of children are not born in
wedlock which is historically
unprecedented and clearly there have
been beneficiaries of that i completely
acknowledge that there is some marriages
that are miserable and abusive and
desperately need to end and people
should be able to have those marriages
but i'm not convinced by the idea that
this has been liberation for everyone i
particularly think that children have
suffered as a consequence of this and i
think poor women in particular have
suffered as well because what we know
from the data is that the
best environment for a stable and
prosperous
family in which to raise children is a
married couple who stay married
but is that necessarily i mean is
marriage does the data show that
marriage is better than two people
cohabiting because what you can what you
get quite a lot in britain and then and
to take sweden for example my wife is
swedish when i got when i proposed to
her uh her friends were kind of shocked
so we didn't she wasn't even pregnant
you know in sweden the way things work
out is you have a baby if things go well
then you might get have another baby if
things go well you might then get
married but it doesn't um it's difficult
to say that the swedish society is any
sort of worse than british because
they've got a cohabiting tradition so is
cohabitation demonstrably worse than
marriage for the child
i don't know the situation in sweden i
wonder if common law marriage is
recognized in law there because that
does change things
one of the things that a lot of people
don't realize here is that we
there aren't you have no rights um
unless you are married formally to
someone so you you there there are all
sorts of negative consequences if you
are if someone dies or you split and
you're not formally married in terms of
things like uh inheritance tax and you
know other other rights that marry
couples but you have civil partnerships
here the blue government introduced this
sort of marriage light at the time
but then interestingly that just seems
to have been
um
i mean it is in technical terms
basically the same as being married just
without the religious aspects it gives
you all of the legal entitlements
doesn't it people don't want to get
married but still want the protection
the legal protection of inheritance and
whatnot but that's been a flop has this
well it doesn't seem to have had the
uptake that one might have expected
people are just
choosing to cohabit and the problem with
cohabitation longer term and in thinking
about children zone is couples who are
cohabiting are much more likely to split
because there seems to be a
when it is just that little bit more
difficult you know every relationship
across
across a lifetime life is very long you
will go through periods of not liking
each other as much and
it seems that when you've got
when it's hard to divorce
people tend to stick with it and are
more likely to push through the tough
times and get to
and um
get to a happier stage where they you
know are pleased to still be together
but if divorce is easy or if
just splitting because you're not even
married in the first place is easy we we
see in the data that people are much
more likely to do it and actually
likely to regret it i was really
surprised to read data on the proportion
of divorced people who regret getting
divorced in this country it's between
about a third and a half
um yeah i know it's really high
some of our listeners might be str find
it strange this argument coming from you
a new statesman writer i mean typically
the rights of being the one talking
about family values and trying to make
it and trying to resist um divorce
reform and the left have been the one
arguing for more liberal structures do
you think the left have miscalculated
here that marriage is a progressive
force
i mean if you look at the data the class
skew
on marriage is absolutely incredible in
this country also in the states and in
other places
you get a
um a liberal elite who
tend to talk negatively about marriage
and our opposed marriage incentives in
policymaking and so forth but they are
actually the group of people who are
most likely to themselves get married
and stay married
so there's a kind of
the if you've heard the expression
luxury belief rob henderson's um
idea of a an idea which confers status
on
rich people and harms poor people
the
anti-marriage
sexual revolution idea is a really great
example of a luxury belief because it's
deeply unfashionable on the left to talk
about marriage being a force for good
but actually
people who
people in elite positions people who who
who are um wealthier upper middle
classes
for themselves love marriage
and and are the group most likely to
choose it for themselves and and wish it
for their children and so on they're
just reluctant to prescribe it for the
rest of society which actually
disproportionately harms poorer people
right so do you think in this case the
progressive cause should be
to promote marriage i mean it seems um
unlikely but i don't know but from what
you're saying if the figures show as you
suggest that marriage first of all is a
tool that benefits people that the rich
tend to get married a lot even though
they advocate liberalism and that then
people in poorer communities are
suffering from the lack of it is this um
a cause which left ought to take up and
what can you do to promote marriage it
sounds a bit hectoring doesn't it for
for any politician to be suggesting to
somebody else how the shooter shouldn't
live their lives
as i say deeply deeply unfashionable but
i think that if we if we're thinking
about children in particular and if
we're concerned about um the various
adverse outcomes that come
for children of of of not growing up in
a house with their fathers at home
talking about things like higher
incarceration rates for boys higher teen
pregnancy rates for girls poorer mental
health for both sexes in all sorts of
ways we know that there is this this
institution you know now now mostly dead
which can improve all of those outcomes
um and actually you know there are all
sorts of ways in in this country that
marriage is actually disincentivized by
the state for instance we don't assess
people's
tax
on the basis of a family it is um
there's very few advantages from being
married in terms of your tax
arrangements because you still have to
pay tax on an individual basis which
means that a single earner household
actually ends up paying a lot more tax
than a dual earner household which is
has been deliberately designed um by the
new labour government that's the sort of
policy that would be quite easy to
change and would provide just that
little little bit of incentive for
people to choose to get married and
choose to stay married with all of the
benefits that brings in terms of both
for individuals and also for families if
this isn't really creeping through in
policy i wonder if it's creeping through
in popular culture let's take for
example beyonce or a great feminist icon
now she
argued about um well quite a few years
ago now that women should be insisting
upon marriage if you like it she said
you should put a ring on it do you think
this will be a feminist um cree dakura
now
well i don't know i mean i where beyonce
goes i suppose we all follow but um
i mean i think it ought to be and i
think i think what's really interesting
and i write about this in the piece at
the end is that um
a lot of um feminist or progressives who
rail against marriage because it's
associated with the religious right and
all of this it's old-fashioned it's
terrible
find ways of kind of reinventing
marriage because actually the the like
central idea of having some sort of
formal legal bond to the person
with whom you're in a sexual
relationship with and even more so with
whom you have a child with there's
actually a great deal of of wisdom to
that there's a reason that he has
persisted down the ages um and so you
have various sort of proposals which
sound actually an awful lot like
marriage
but um
just don't have that that that term i
think i was fascinated in your article
that you mentioned um something called
radical monogamy a phrase i hadn't heard
acros come across before but it's
mentioned by vice magazine recently what
is radical monogamy and is it just
another word for marriage yeah radical
monogamy apparently is when you
deliberately choose to be monogamous
having sort of
properly assessed all of the other
options rather than just being
monogamous by default because that's
what the culture tells you you ought to
do i do not see any meaningful
difference between those two things the
outcome is exactly the same and it's a
good one you know we know i mean on the
the subject of polyamory so that's
what's been presented as the alternative
to monogamy right and there are and
there are various pushes to um to
formalize polyamory and permit um permit
multiple marriages and so on i don't
know if they're gonna go anywhere one of
the things i write about in the book
is that um
monogamous marriage is not only good for
individuals with children it also has
effects on the whole of our society
which are really remarkable
societies where monogamous marriages
formalised in law
tend to be more prosperous they tend to
have lower rates of
violence they don't have lower rates of
domestic abuse and child abuse there are
all sorts of ways that you know because
all of this is networks right like kind
of the point i'm trying to make in the
book is this isn't just about individual
choices isn't just about individual
freedom this is thinking about
the what the the well-being of society
as a whole
and
monogamous marriages had turned out
historically to be this amazing tool for
promoting
a flourishing society
and the progressive force for feminism
that's my argument yeah
louise perry thank you so much for
joining us on spectator tv
we're almost coming up to a hundred days
in the war in ukraine so how's it going
my colleague andrews caught up with two
eminent historians anthony beaver and
sir haiflohe here she is in conversation
with them
anthony and sergey thank you for joining
spectator tv anthony can you please
start by giving us an update on the war
in ukraine
well the latest developments uh are
rather alarming
the
encirclement or in imminent encirclement
of several donetsk uh could cut off uh a
fairly large number of troops in an
impossible position
uh it implies that the
real attempt at the moment is to
uh completely seize um the
uh the hans garria andersk and
basically cut off ukraine from the black
sea entirely
now that is uh deeply worrying because
it means that putin
could then say right we will
negotiate on this particular basis
and
ukraine will be completely vulnerable
and could be attacked at any further
point in the future
so i don't see i don't see any
acceptance of a uh truce let alone a
piece uh based on those sort of uh on
that sort of situation
uh so i think that it is a worrying
development and uh i see the i would
have thought
the war has got to go on really until
the late autumn right into the winter at
this particular stage and the
destruction will be utterly devastating
sir the russian forces are reaching what
looks increasingly like a stalemate in
the east of ukraine do you think that's
the best way to describe it
they're still on the offensive and there
is a real danger that uh
one of the major cities in east of
ukraine the seven of the nets can be
completely surrendered
and then we could potentially see the
replay of the mario story which is um
awful story tragic
story on on many levels so this is this
is the
mo the most dangerous moment in in that
stage of the war
if ukraine manages to avoid the
encirclement and withstands that
pressure the most likely scenario is
indeed a stalemate a stalemate not only
in the east in the luhansk area and
donetsk area but also in the south
and most likely what will be happening
after that there will be a month or two
of preparation
most likely for the resumption of the
military actions ukraine is waiting for
a heavy armament coming from
the western allies
the decisions has been made politically
financially and otherwise but it takes
time to deliver those weapons it takes
time to train officers and soldiers
because at this point ukraine is
outgunned and probably outnumbered and
outgunned what i mean is that the
artillery that ukraine has it actually
can't reach as far as the
russian artillery reaches and in this
counter
in this war between the artilleries and
batteries ukrainians are ill-equipped to
to win that kind of war uh anthony last
time we spoke russia was just beginning
to refocus its campaign away from keeve
which felt like a temporary victory for
ukraine uh that they were refocusing
away from the capital but did that lull
us into a full sense of security did we
overestimate that that temporary victory
for ukraine given all the problems for
its troops that sir he just mentioned
well i think there was a certain amount
of optimism but i do remember um having
heard from you know
various uh experts here particularly the
ministry of defense there was a
a severe uh concern that actually they
would then adopt the russians would then
adopt a much more
aggressive strategy
and attempt to encircle and cut off uh
the main ukrainian forces in the east uh
and this i think we're starting to see
now so i don't think it was totally
unpredictable but it's true that
the shock of seeing uh the russian army
starting in many cases almost to
disintegrate
the bad morale the
refusal of troops sometimes to accept
orders and even
withdrawals which had not been prepared
and also their inability to use their
own equipment very effectively uh did
certainly boost the idea um that there
was a real chance of uh a ukrainian
victory now um i think that uh reality
has certainly shown itself that it is
going to be a very very tough struggle
indeed uh and uh as uh quite rightly
said you know until the ukrainians can
really have
an equality in firepower particularly an
artillery which
the russians have always relied on
in a major way both
in recent wars whether
in chechnya or
in
[Music]
syria as well as of course during the
second world war where it referred to
its artillery as the god of war
um but until the ukrainians can really
match that as uh as has just been said
um we are going to see a very very tough
time for the ukrainian forces so um
there's a there's a long way to go
before we
start to see any real improvement and so
here i'm interested in those comments
because a lot of attention has been paid
to the tens of billions of dollars
flowing from the united states to
ukraine and from many other countries
around the world along with military
equipment and the guns as you put it um
and and again this has made people feel
relatively optimistic that ukraine's
military budget could even surpass
russia's but it's this time lag that you
mentioned that in the meantime before
that money and that training can all
catch up this is a very difficult time
for the ukrainian army army
it is a very difficult time and the
help that is being provided both in
terms of the
weapons and military equipment and
finances are essential for ukraine being
able to fight
that being said the the money that is
being provided don't amount even to half
of the russia's yearly budget so it's
it's a lot of money but it's not not on
par what with the kind of resources that
russia has
at this point
uh
ukrainians really surprised uh the world
with their resilience with the kind of
resistance that they show
in the fight against the most probably
feared army in the world so far
they also exposed the weaknesses of that
army and anthony was was talking about
some of them
i also when i read the reports from the
front lines in ukraine and about the
russian army being engaged in all this
war crimes and and abuses and looting
and so on and so forth what comes to my
mind are scenes from anthony's books on
world war ii it looks like we have this
70 80 years passed but the
the way how the russian army fights its
wars didn't change much
and again artillery is extremely
important part of that story and it's
the story of destruction of the cities
from aleppo to mario pill starting in uh
horazni and in grozny in chechnya and
now now we have
this battle in east of ukraine in
several the nets so um
it can be it can be really really very
costly in in every possible way but
mostly in terms of the lost lives and
and completely destroyed destroyed
infrastructure so the sooner ukraine can
get the equipment it needs
the better and the less the less
suffering they will be and on that point
sir he the government in kiev looks like
it's getting back to work parts of the
country have reopened if the war does
continue for months or even years what
will life be like for ukrainians there
this is exactly the question that
many many people in ukraine and outside
of ukraine ask themselves
how to adjust to life like that
and also in terms of rebuilding ukraine
or reinvesting in ukraine if the low
intensity work continues how safe are
these investments and and this
rebuilding efforts
and it looks like there is no
very clear answers at this point except
that answers come with very practical
steps
that ukrainians and other
allies are taking at this moment and as
we speak the number of ukrainians that
are living poland for ukraine so going
back to ukraine is now significantly
higher than the number of ukrainians
living in ukraine for central europe
which tells you a lot about about the
sentiment in ukraine
and the fact that the western embassies
including the uk embassy that left
ukraine before the attack
sending of course the decision was
absolutely correct as we know now but
sending terrible terrible sign in terms
of the morale to the to people in
ukraine
now those embassies and uk embassy in
particular are back sending a very
positive signal to to ukraine and to the
world
so i guess we will be we will be um
providing the sense as to what to do in
the context of the continuing war as as
things develop but
as as at this point there are some signs
of
limited normalization in terms of
political life in terms of the economic
life and military and the ukrainian
society and the world adjusting to these
conditions of the war no one believes
anymore that the war would last 72 hours
that ukraine would would fail so
the armed forces of ukraine showed the
ability to to hold the line
and possibly go on the offensive at some
point anthony the researcher for your
new book alexi avashian is now actually
on the front lines where the ukrainians
are working to push the russians back
can you tell us about your relationship
and have you spoken to him
no i haven't managed to speak to him um
but uh we've been sort of in uh indirect
touch and
from having sort of having to give up if
you like his reader's card in the
archives um he is now um
fighting as a rifleman medic
with the 10th battalion of the
territorial defense um in fact actually
um any a lot of us uh various friends
have been crowdfunding equipment for
them of night vision um stuff and things
like that and i think that the more we
can do it's not just a question of
governments and providing the artillery
on a much lower level you know any
crowdfunding of
buying vehicles and so forth
is a tremendous help and i think that
everybody can do what they what they can
in those circumstances but coming back a
little bit to um what was sort of said
earlier um we are seeing very much as
saki rightly said you know a a
repetition of the previous atrocities
committed
particularly here in say 1945 by the red
army
um and there's been i think an
increasing debate of where
all of this brutality comes from the way
that even russian soldiers are treated
um
in the same way rather as the red army
was often treated by its end commanders
in the second world war
with a contempt and also uh with total
lack of feeling
so
um the the debate to a certain degree is
sort of you know where does all of this
uh
brutality as uh
one
columnist wrote you know this uh this
casual savagery come from and i think
that uh it is an important one i mean
one can't generalize because obviously
there is no
dna of national character but at the
same time there is a question of
self-image and i i do feel that a lot of
this goes back a very very long way i
mean it goes perhaps back all to the
mongol invasions of the 13th century
that you
believe that uh the frightfulness of war
the cruelty and savagery uh is a
legitimate um
or a natural uh weapon of war
um and the
certainly the crimes that have been
committed uh of which more and more have
been become um
evident uh just literally in the last
couple of weeks um
shows that actually things haven't
changed very much in that particular way
there is an attitude really that
brutality is a form of strength um and i
think that this comes much more not
obviously not from as i say a a national
characteristic but much more from a
national self-image and
um there is this sort of russian
criminal view of strengths uh which is
totally linked to uh a form of brutality
sir he your new book adams and ashes
looks at nuclear disasters and there are
nuclear reactors around the area of this
conflict at the beginning there were
worries that one of them had actually
been shelled should we still be worried
about an accidental escalation of this
war
yes yes we should
i really didn't imagine when the war
started that the nuclear theme would
re-emerge and not in the way how most
people think about nuclear in a sense of
the use of nuclear weapons there were
noises about that as well but in a very
unexpected way that the war would come
to the nuclear power sides and on the
first day of the war uh the russian army
in unmarked uniforms took over control
over the chernobyl nuclear site the site
of the worst
nuclear accident in history and then a
few days later there was an attack a
military attack with shelling on the the
parisian nuclear power plant the largest
nuclear power plant in europe and one of
the buildings caught fire the nuclear
power plant was was taken the the
national guards of ukraine were
overpowered three of them lost their
lives
and the personnel was held hostage so
this is this is a recipe for disaster
recipe for another for another accident
we were extremely lucky that it didn't
come to that that the russian troops
were also stopped a few a few dozen
kilometers away
from the southern ukrainian nuclear
power plant another nuclear power plant
and
this is a concern not just for ukraine
this is a concern for the entire world
because we are facing a new reality war
comes to the nuclear power plants
440 reactors exist today in the world
and none of them was designed with an
eye on the ability to withstand shelling
or to be part of the of the
object or subject of the of the military
takeover
uh we are not
we don't even know where to start to
think about that what that means
and uh this is this is a new reality
this is the new reality of the war and
and a sort of brutality a sort of
mindedness that has been part of of this
war and the way how it is waged by the
russian federation and anthony was
talking about the national character and
dna i certainly absolutely agree with
that
i want to add that there are
institutions and there are certain
institute
traditions within those institutions and
what we saw in the last few months is
that the russian army
really is in many ways unreformed
uh red army or soviet army of the 40s
50s and 80s
and the commanders that are in charge
today they started their careers
certainly in the soviet union in the 70s
and 80s
and that is that is certainly something
that
is not part of the strength of the
russian armed forces but part of the
weakness
uh anthony what do you make of the
argument that if the west keeps arming
ukraine and keeps encouraging ukraine to
fight
that it might encourage putin to
eventually use nuclear weapons or to
target nuclear reactors escalating the
war even further
well that danger exists i mean we are
seeing um a recklessness um
with the attacks on say the nuclear
power stations but also uh in the
general
conduct to the war which is terrifying
whether or not uh putin is
seriously ill close to death or whatever
um really does raise a very major
danger that he may be prepared to go
really to the to the very limits um
partly i suppose you know to have his
own uh legacy in history or whatever as
the man who tried to restore not so much
the soviet union but the russian empire
and his in his mentality
um
but the very fact of the anger the
humiliation of failing to achieve that
quick victory which he had expected um
is deeply deeply worrying
but i i think that the other
thing we should add is um what's very
striking is the way that putin is now
trying to micromanage the war
um
rather in the way that hitler did during
the most disastrous moments of the last
part of the second world war
uh ironically it was stalin who uh was a
disastrous leader at the beginning but
then suddenly learned in 42 in late 42
that he had to give the uh the generals
in their heads so that they could uh
control matters and then actually he
became quite an effective uh war leader
but um here we're seeing putin actually
following the uh hitler the disaster
of uh of meddling
um and i think that uh the the generals
are in a very very difficult position
indeed
uh and unable obviously to control it so
i think it is again another aspect of
why the situation is so dangerous
last question to both of you sir he uh
in last week's spectator magazine our
political editor james forsythe wrote
about zelensky's choice should the
ukrainian president negotiate or keep
fighting how do you see this war finally
coming to an end
zelinski emerged as a very effective
war leader something that no one really
expected
that that would be happening
he is
in my opinion consciously unconsciously
emulates churchill at least in the way
how
how he mobilizes the masses in terms of
his
speeches
he doesn't emulate churchill in a sense
that he lives the war to the generals
which was a very very smart choice
in my opinion zelinski is about
his political talent is about feeling
and understanding what the people want
and he is an amplifier as a politician
and what we see in ukraine today is that
even at the worst the most
the
the most dangerous moments of the war
during the first days of the war the
percentage of the ukrainians who
believed in the victory was never
lower than 70 percent
so the people of ukraine are really not
prepared to trade territory for peace
that was president zelensky's position
at the very
beginning when he was elected in 2019 at
the very start of the war and it
continues to be today so the actual
borders probably will be
decided at the battleground but in terms
of the
ukrainian recognition of any annexations
whatsoever including the annexation of
the crimea that is this is off the table
and it's not just about zelensky or
people around him this is this is the
mood
in the country
on the other hand zebenski sent a signal
at the very very early on that there can
be all sorts of different arrangements
not just a nato membership
what he is interested in and what the
ukrainians are interested in is a piece
that actually can stand with the
guarantees not assurances of the kind
that ukraine got in 20 uh
in 20 or
in 1994
with the budapest memorandum
where the nuclear weapons were taken out
of ukraine creating this security vacuum
which was replaced with nothing
and what uh
the only way how the
war can be defeated and the peace can
come if ukraine becomes part of a very
serious solid
security arrangement the the new
architecture regional architecture of
security has to be designed either with
the particip certainly with the
participation of the old existing
organizations but either within them or
out of them that's that's the ukrainian
position
right now right today and
i just don't see how how the war would
when would end otherwise i mean would
really end not end with armistice if
there is no
really very strong security guarantees
to ukraine anthony do you agree with
siri's assessment
absolutely
in fact the only assurance for ukraine
would be to become a member of nato to
make sure because we cannot trust they
cannot trust uh putin's word uh for a
moment and he might well pull back uh uh
as napoleon said for myself ready to
jump again and attack again
so unless there is some sort of castle
guarantee
like membership of nato
that russia will not uh
invade or attack or basically harass
in a an existential way um the
sovereignty of ukraine in the future um
the war will drag on and i think that
zelinski is absolutely right we do not
want to see the west trying to force uh
ukraine into a compromise
um
which will be
fairly similar to what happened to
czechoslovakia at munich
sir he and anthony thank you so much for
joining spectator tv
now this weekend marks the anniversary
of the tiananmen square massacre
something which you can't really say in
chinese media i'd be censored device
tried to say that on social media
interestingly it's also been taken out
of chinese films and books so there's
hardly any references to what is
referred only even mystically now as the
fourth of june events
my colleague cindy looks back on this in
her column of the magazine this week
cindy and thanks for joining me now you
say you only really found out about this
when you were visiting hong kong in your
early twenties how can them an event so
big historically be kept out of the
national conversation in china
yeah i was born five years after
tiananmen square incident so i wasn't
actually alive when it happened but by
that point it had already been scrubbed
out of you know textbooks it had been
scrubbed out of reporting um hong kong
having not been handed over to china at
that stage was actually one of the
places where you could be closest to the
action and also see what was happening
without being censored um so there was a
lot of footage there and i think that's
you know instilled in the city this uh
tradition of remembering tiamon which is
something that i saw when i went um even
though i grew up in mainland china and i
went to hong kong in my early 20s
hong kong university there used to be a
sculpture called the pillar of shame
which is this gruesome orange
atrocity really but the ugliness of the
sculpture is really going to show the
ugliness of what happened on the square
in that day now that sculpture is now
gone and last year the authorities
removed it as we know hong kong has been
undergoing this kind of mainlinization
of politics and so people going to hong
kong now wouldn't have the same
education as i had when i went and
growing up we just didn't really talk
about it we i kind of knew maybe that it
had happened it was
you know it was june 4th but nobody
really said anything about it i
certainly didn't learn about it in any
history books and so i didn't really
fully understand it i think until i went
to hong kong and then your columns and
you look at how china has changed since
chairman and
your economic figures are quite striking
yeah so the world bank has a um poverty
standard of uh under 1.9 uh dollars a
day um in china before at the time of
tiaman it was about 60 of chinese people
were living under that poverty line now
that includes people in my family
because you know we've generationally
always been in china today that
percentage is 0.1 under the world bank's
um poverty line so this has happened in
the last 40 years and it's an incredible
incredible change and to my family and
to me that's not just statistics you
know that is literally people's lives
getting longer it is people's lives
getting better more education um it's
it's really a bit of a whiplash i write
about in my in my piece when you think
about how much people's lives have
changed in such a short period of time
my grandmother was born before the
communist takeover she was one of 10
siblings
she couldn't finish her schooling
because they had only money to give her
older sister that opportunity and she
had to get married very young in order
to be secure in her life my mother was
born in the cultural revolution when my
grandmother was actually being denounced
by the red guards
and then when i came along in the 90s
you know life was relatively good i had
an education
being a girl i wasn't really treated to
any discrimination you know there was of
course a one-child policy um i had
enough to eat i had clothes on my back
then i was able to leave the country get
a foreign education and now i'm here and
you know that experience is actually not
very exceptional when you look at a lot
of chinese people because of that
statistical change it's just amazing
what has happened um but i think you
know i think what what has
shown a lot of chinese people in recent
months with zero xerocovid policy is
that actually no matter how much wealth
you have if the chinese communist party
doesn't want you to do something or if
it wants you to do something modern
chinese still doesn't have that much
choice well i remember at the time after
1989 there was talk about the end of
history about how liberal democracy
would prevail in the end a lot of people
saw chinese communism as an anachronism
something that might not have toppled at
tiananmen but it would topple as a
country grew wealthier now the country
did go through this incredible wealth
that you demonstrate no real appetites
for liberal democracy or if there was it
wasn't something that politically
managed to express itself why is that do
you think it's because the communists
were able to convincingly say
that to the chinese you've never had it
so good our formula is working just look
at what's happened in the last few
decades
yeah absolutely i mean economic growth
was amazing this year the economic
growth is predicted to be around five
percent or at least that's the ccp
target
that sounds good to us but that's the
lowest that's been in three decades so
you just imagine the kind of economic
growth the country has been through and
while it was going while it was going
good while it was going well why would
you want to rock the boat as an average
chinese and i think i we also have to
say here that 92 percent of chinese
people are han chinese so the kind of
ethnic minority suppression is not
something that your average chinese
person in a kind of majority city in a
wealthier part of the country is going
to be thinking about so i think that i
have to carry out that one but yes
people are happy to you know give over
certain freedoms in order to have better
longer lives which is not just
materialistic by the way it really does
mean it's a moral issue for me it's an
ethical issue that you know people like
me could go to have an education so i
think that that was the trade-off um but
the economy is now slowing so the
question is in the next 10 20 years is
that trade officer going to hold is that
contract still going to hold or are
people going to be thinking well
actually you're not really doing well
for me anymore
and you say that shanghai lockdown could
be potentially turning points
yeah i think so i think so because you
know you ask a wiga for example in china
and they will tell you that the system
is not working you're asking a hand
chinese person two years ago was the
system working for you yeah it would
have been really um because even if you
were one of the working classes you
still have more opportunities than you
know your previous generations and your
family would have done for the reasons
i've explained but i think what the
shanghai lockdown has done is so
shocking because
it is the most educated the wealthiest
city in the country and what it has
shown those people is that no matter how
much wealth you have no matter how much
education you have you can't you don't
have the political freedom that those
students in tiananmen square in 1989
were fighting for you still don't have
that even if life on the surface seems
better
you know it really makes people think
how much do i really have you know what
really matters in my life
why do i have to go to state quarantine
if i if i've only been come in contact
with someone who's asymptomatic you know
all of these questions have been asked
by very middle-class chinese people who
so far have been happy to just sit sit
on their backsides
right but tiananmen wasn't as it turned
out a turning point and
isn't really any serious reason to
believe that
the shanghai lockdown could be because
in previously chinese people have shown
an incredible ability to put up with
political repression to play up with
censorship you mentioned a new piece
about how chinese films and everything
have been censored a lot more
in the last couple of decades than they
were before so there was a kind of
artistic flourishing pushed into reverse
but you say this is not against the
protests of the chinese population you
say the film goers if anything aren't
particularly interested in the
avant-garde film that was being served
up a couple of decades ago
yeah of course and i think i think it's
always hard to generalize about the
chinese people as 1.4 billion people a
fifth of the world's population so when
we're talking about her we do have to be
careful when we say this is what people
would believe because scientifically we
don't have polling data for obvious
reasons so what i'm worried about is if
you look at the film industry it's films
like wolf warrior and wolf warrior 2
that are topping box offices rather than
the amazing kind of subversive both
politically and socially subversive
things that we saw um in the aftermath
of the cultural revolution for a few
decades and that was the stuff that was
winning international awards you know
westerners and the chinese liked it
because it was challenging the history
that had happened so if i was showing
for the first time on the big screen the
suffering that you know my country's
people had been under
that has gone into reverse in the film
industry and i worry that it's not just
a top-down thing from census i worry
that it's also people becoming more
narrow-minded people becoming more
hubristic about how china is good now
and therefore they don't have to worry
about that kind of stuff i think the
shanghai is a moment for people to
rethink that but i i think you're right
you know people just say tiananmen
square what's going to be a turning
point people are always talking about
chernobyl moment with china and it never
really comes because the communist party
is just so much more resilient than a
lot of people give it give the credit
for um so all i can say is that i hope
that this makes people reconsider um but
even if they do there's not much they
can do about that
and you've got a feeling as to what
direction china is going in in general
would you want to say where we're going
to be i don't them in 10 years time and
more or less liberal china is the
communist party's grip going to be as
strong as it is now are there any real
reasons to see any real domestic
pressure for a political change
i think that economics is the one to
keep an eye on because
you know
previously at the beginning of this
century people thought this was going to
be the moment when china overtakes the
us as the world's largest economy i'm
not even sure if that's actually going
to happen now if you look at the
slowdown of the chinese economy not
least due to the zero-covered policy so
if sudin ping can't get his head around
the economics if he can't solve that
problem then a huge source of legitimacy
is going to be gone so where does he go
for illegitimacy next it's probably
going to be nationalism and we don't
know what that is going to look like
because the communist party is quite
wary about unleashing some kind of
nationalism because arguably that's what
we saw in cultural revolution where you
know you unleash just people's power and
then you couldn't really bring it back
um so i don't know what it's going to be
like in the next 10 years but i can say
that economic miracle that i was just
talking about is not going to be
repeated or continued in the next decade
cindy thanks very much and of course you
can follow developments in chinese life
and society in cindy's fortnightly
podcast chinese whispers to find out
more about it go to spectator dot co dot
uk forward slash whispers
now we all know how difficult it is to
get a face-to-face appointment with a gp
nowadays but why might that be
in this week's magazine marian thomas
who is in the nhs for
40 years writes about a new system
called total triage which was introduced
during the pandemic
and governs gp clinics still
welcome to spectator tv can you tell us
a bit about turtle triage what is it
total triage was announced by the
government in march 2020 and the idea
was
that to protect um gps their staff and
indeed patients from covid
so that patients were not allowed just
to turn up a gp surgeries they had to
phone up or
send an email with their complaints
explain what was wrong sometimes quite
personal embarrassing complaints and
then they would be allocated either to a
a phone call or rarely a face-to-face
face-to-face consultation or
referral to another health professional
such as a pharmacist
uh the trouble is that that system is
not going to be reversed it's carrying
on it's great for the gps they love it
and they don't want to turn the clock
back um on triage
so what was introduced as an emergency
system for the pandemic is now the new
normal
it's now the new normal receding in
response to public opposition i think
but it's still the new normal yes right
now you see in your article that gps
despite um seeing fewer face-to-face
patients never before are still quite
unhappy and very few of them are working
in five-day weeks and
i i don't quite understand what the
problem is if they're you know the pay
is not entirely ungenerous the hours
from what you say are evolved fewer
face-to-face contacts never before so
what's is why there is so many gps
saying but they intend to leave general
practice within a couple of years
surveys regularly say but they're very
very unhappy they find the pressure
untenable it seems the system isn't
working for them as well as the patients
that's right they um say that they're
suffering from burnout and as i
explained in my article i don't quite
understand that because i was a surgeon
in the nhs with a cancer surgeon for 33
years i don't remember seeing any
colleagues being burned out
but the real problem um in
general practice phraser is part-time
working um so if we know that 58 percent
of gps work part-time
they work three days or less and that is
absolutely atrocious
so there are 70 000 gps on the gmc gp
register
40
000 of those work part time three days
or less and 25 000 of those work two
days or less
so this is the point that's never made
by the royal college of gps or by the
bma the reason that patients have
difficulty finding access to gps
is
not because primarily we haven't got
enough gps but because the gps we've got
are all working part-time
and there are horrible consequences of
that and i think
that
the iran college of gps and the bma
should actually apologize to the public
and make it clear
that one of the big problems is
of access to gps is that so many of them
are working part time so that spins off
to the fact that patients don't get
continuity of care which is the thing
they most value
spins off to the fact that the gps have
to employ so many locums and i talk
about the national association of
sessional gps and it even spins off to
the fact that
um gps or the general practice is
missing early cancers because there is
no continuity of care and again that is
something a point i make in my article
and you say in an article that the
recessional gps i guess would have been
writing describing effectively freelance
gp to go from clinton to clinic now
account for one in four gps which raises
obvious issues for a kind of continuity
of service if you're not seeing the same
doctor of a doctor it's just coming into
a place where he's not going to see the
same people so are we now seeing also
the erosion not simply a full-time gps
but of of practices where you might be
right
you might understand a decent chance of
seeing the same faces yeah
absolutely there's no such thing as
practice that you a patient having a
name gp anymore you're a patient of the
practice not of the of the gp so that
you can be seen by the gp salary gp or
any number of locums that might be in or
out i call them
come today gone tomorrow
uh
locums and it's
what i don't understand is why this
erosion has been allowed to take place
where is the department of health in not
stopping this you have to remember that
almost all of these doctors have been
educated at public expense
and they seem to have no responsibility
or feeling of
having to give something back to the nhs
and yet very early on in their careers
they've decided work life balance et
cetera i'm just going to become a locum
gp work for an agency have no
permanent linkage to a general practice
have no personal contact or offer my
patients continuity of care why hasn't
it why has the department of health
allowed this to happen and i think one
of the problems is that the department
of health is scared of the bma and they
it's basically the relationship with the
with the bma is one of appeasement
rather than
directing what should happen there seems
to be no accountability um there's not
very good management and i think one of
the solutions i would have suggested is
that gps should be employed by the nhs
at the moment they are independent
contractors if they're employed by the
nhs then they would have um a job plan
everybody would know what they were
doing they'd have to keep the job plan
but because they're independent
contractors they can basically do as
they wish but we went through all that
didn't we tony blair had this massive
big new contract with gps in 2004 and
there was that was supposed to be
getting better value for the taxpayer
what happened there
well that's what they said but the 2004
contract phrase i think is the big is
the beginning of the slippery slope for
general practice so what happened uh gps
were only required to work
week day office hours
they had no responsibility
in the evenings at at night at weekends
or on
bank holidays
so
what actually happened then was
the the responsibility for urgent care
essentially fell onto accident emergency
departments and that's where
the rot started so gps basically only
had to be responsible for 40 hours
for their patients for 40 hours of 164
hour week
now medical emergencies don't happen
just in those for 40 hours they occur
randomly throughout the week and one of
the tragedies of that um
phraser is this you know emergency care
in
medicine
the management of of urgently of sick
patients is one of the most rewarding
things in general practice
um to see a patient who's really unwell
to make a diagnosis either to make them
better or to put them on the right
pathway to getting better that is the
most rewarding one of the most rewarding
things of all now still because of the
new contract
gps rarely see urgent patients
they obviously get de-skilled
worst of all the trainees in general
practice also working 40 hours a week or
less
um
are not taught um
or have no experience of the management
of managing sick patients because they
don't see them out of hours so we're
told that sasha javid wants to be a
reforming health secretary we're told
boris johnson wants to be a reforming
prime minister what would your advice be
to them would it be to basically to try
to get another contract with the gps
because that might mean stuffing their
mouths with gold yes again
well sanji javid gave 260 million pounds
to gps last year to improve access you
remember that
and uh
the one thing that the royal college of
gps on the bma could have done was to
say to gps look why don't you work an
extra session or two every week
paid for out of the 260 million from
sergey javid just to get us over
the uh post
covet hump
just imagine how much goodwill that
would do in the community just imagine
what the patients would think of you
you'd restore all the respect that
you've lost during the total triage but
of course they didn't do it
so the question you asked me was what
should sacha javi do the first thing is
with any problem fraser you've got to
accept that there is a problem and the
extent of the problem and do a root
cause analysis the root cause analysis
is uh gps only work for 40 hours out of
the one six four hours a week
they uh the they work part-time why are
they allowed to work such
appallingly
minimal hours why isn't part-time
working for example 40 hours a week i
would regard that as being
fair and respectable what other
profession is allowed to just
pick and choose what hours they work
change their contracts willy-nilly uh i
think that sergey chavit and the
department need to take more control of
the situation
brilliant thomas thanks very much for
joining us on spectator tv and that's it
for this week i hope you have a great
jubilee weekend if you'd like to
subscribe to this um youtube channel
then you can just click on subscribe
under the box and you should get a
little notice every time there's a new
episode of the week in 60 minutes
i'd like to thank max jeffrey our
producer and the spec tv team do join us
next week
[Music]
you